And I would ague that all three arguments here are in a way correct.
So you could argue that randomization is more powerful than determinism.
Of course, we don't know why and we don't know if that is so,
but it could be a valid reason that somehow randomization is a bit more effective
but I think you could argue that randomization is in a way
or that randomization could in a way be a bit more effective than determinism.
After all, you're not really saying how much more effective,
but maybe you gain a little edge through trying randomization.
Of course it could also be that simply no one has had the right idea yet
how to design a really really good deterministic algorithm for 3-SAT.
Of course, the links of the table that I've just shown you suggest
that people have put a lot of thought into this but maybe tomorrow,
somebody comes up with a really good idea for a comparably
fast exponential time algorithm for 3-SAT, and finally, I think this is also an important point,
it could be that analyzing deterministic algorithms is just way more complex
than analyzing the randomized ones.
The 3-SAT algorithm, the randomized one that I've shown you
with a running time of 1.334^n  some polynomial is very very simple
and it's analysis is also not that complicated.
For the deterministic algorithms, however, you have to go through
a lot and lot and lot of analysis to prove those bounds.
So, it could be that you could modify some deterministic algorithm
to be better than the randomized one but simply the analysis required to do so, is much more complex
and by analysis, I really mean that you don't really have to modify the algorithm that much
but just look at its performance a little more closely.
So, there are couple of reasons why the randomized 3-SAT algorithms
could be better than the deterministic ones, but of course, we don't know for sure.